number one the trailer places a pretty
big emphasis on magical creatures number
two we know we'll be able to tame
magical creatures this has been
confirmed by the devs and we also see it
in the trailer with this grab horn
number three okay this one really threw
me and it is when i started thinking
okay this has a pretty good shot of
actually happening i think take a look
at what these dark wizards are wearing
here that's right animal skulls now
maybe they're not dark wizards you say
but whatever the case may be it does
look as if we the player will be
battling it out with these wizards at
some point there's actually even more
though number four there are two
instances in the trailer of magical
creatures being restrained and breaking
free in what appears to be attacking the
player we have this scene with the troll
where you can see two chains clearly
visible on its wrist but even more than
that look at the background of the
screenshot here all along here we can
see chains in what appears to be some
sort of temple or cave